[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 برنامج
بدايه
الحرب العالميه الاولى
بنفيرو وزير الامن الاسرائيلي المدام
بالعنصريه ياخذون تنياهو في رحله مفخخه
داخليا وخارجيا وفي ملفات الساعه 60
كمبيوتر
كلمات السر تحقيقا مع الفدرالي يكبر
الصوره وماسك الجمهوريون يزيدون الضغط
في جبهه اخرى ايضا يستنفر شركات
التكنولوجيا في حربه مع ابل فهل نتاثر نحن
[موسيقى]
مراكز الاقليميات بشكل غير اعتيادي لا
هجمات صاروخيه او بطائرات المسيره لروسيا
منذ الثالث والعشرين من نوفمبر الماضي على
كيف بحسب السي ان ان لكن ما الاسباب
نفذت المسيرات الايرانيه التي تستخدمها
روسيا طلبت موسكو الفناء و 2700 طائره
جديده او اكثر يؤكد المتحدث باسمي القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه لكن رغم ذلك هناك امراض
الاول انك لم تستعدوا لي هجمات جديده عمده
المدينه ريتال يتحدث ويبدو انه هدوء اي
يسبق العاصفه الثاني هو انه هو رغم
الانخفاض الحادث في الهجمات على البنيه
التحتيه وشبكات الطاقه اوكرانيا لا تزالت
عني من انقطاع الكهرباء
الروسيه كانت قويه للغايه اذا هدوء انا
سيجعل الطرفين يستعدان المعارك ول توقف
هدنه وربما للشتاء دور في ذلك وهنا موسكو
تتحيا من المرشح ان تقوم بنزع الرؤوس
حربيه نوويه من الصواريخ كروز القديمه
واستبدالها برؤوس المعدنيه الثقيله
لاستخدامها في قصف الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وهذا تقييم للاستخبارات العسكريه
البريطانيه والسبب استنزاف مخزون روسيا من
الاسلحه بعيده المدام ياخذنا هذا توقع الى
باب اخر خطر كان لا ينقص العالم تتطرق
اليه الان معاهده اليوستار بين الولايات
المتحده وروسيا اتفاقا وقع في 2010 للحد
من الترسانه النوويه للقوتين
250 نوويه لكل منه معك حدا اقصى بعيده جدا
عن واقعي ثلاث سنتين مددت الاتفاقيات في
بدايه 2021 ل 5 سنوات اي حتى
2026 لسوء الحظ المعاهده اقيم مشهد
المهيمن في الحرب الاوكرانيه روسيا التي
تضع السلاح النووي خيارا لها على الطاوله
اجلت اجتماع مناقشه استئنا في عمليات
التفتيش بموجب معاهده الولايات المتحده من
ناحيتها كانت متهيا لكنها لم تتلقى اجابه
حقيقيه لتفسير اسباب التاجيل الروسي بحسب
جون كيربي المتحدث باسمي المجلس الامن
القومي ربما فاتته تصريحات
ناصر
[موسيقى]
اجواء والتصريحات تعيدنا بالزمن الى
الوراء الى الحرب البارده سباق والتسلح
النووي كان جزءا كبيرا منها بالطبع
وللصدفه اليوم الثالث من ديسمبر هو ذكرى
اعلان الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق جورج بوش
الاب والزعيم السوبياتي الراحل ميخائيل
غربه شوف انهاء الحرب البارده ونحن في عام
1989 في قمه مالطا سفينه الركاب
السوفياتيه مكسيم جورج شاهده على الاعلان
التاريخي والفستان
ورغم اقتراح الامر في عهد رونا دراجن لكن
جورج بوش الاب هو الذي وقع معاهده ستارت
مع الاتحاد السوفيتي للحد من الترسانه
النوويه في اخر يوم في شهر يوليو
1991 المفارقه انه في اليوم التالي
واين في اوكرانيا وعامه تحدث النزعه
القوميه نهايه الشهر
انهار الاتحاد السوفيتي
اللقاءات التي شهدت انها الحرب البارده
بين برج الاب وغربه شوف قد تتكرر اليوم او
السبيل انهاء حرب اوكرانيا
يؤكد انه مستعد للتحدث
اذا كان الشرط هو مغادره موسكو لاوكرانيا
فالامر صعب وفي المقلب الاخر واشنطن لكن
من ناحيه زنسكي لن نضغط عليه للتفاوض يبدو
ان الهدوء الذي تحدثنا عنها فتحى المجال
لملفات عده
نعود بتاريخ اكثر للوراء من الحرب البارده
الى الحرب العالميه الاولى تتشابه المعارك
بتكرار المعطيات الصوره لمعركه ولدت من
جديد اختلف المكان والزمان لتستحضر
اوكرانيا حرب الخنادق ام معارك الحرب
العالميه الاولى لكن بنسختها الحديثه
وقياده لا ترغب فيه هدنه وهنا الخيار واحد
الجنود يلجاون للخنادق وبالعوده الى
الشتاء عام 1916 جبهه الشرقي فرنسا تحديدا
الجنرال فيليب ترامب قرر حفره فنادق
للدفاع عن فردان بعد ان تحول الماني الى
هجوم كاسح المسافه بين الجيشين في حرب
الخنادق يحددها مدى المدفعيه وكما فعل
الجنرال الالماني
حشدت روسيا عددا هائلا من مدفعيتها من اجل
محمود النتيجه واحده حتى الان الا لم
يسيطر على بردان ولم يتقدموا الا مسافه
سته كيلومترات
التشابهه يظهر ايضا في الشتاء في بيضاء
اثرت هل اوحال على الالمان فقدوا 340 الف
جندي وفي الصوره المقابله ولنفس السبب منذ
بدايه الحرب بخموت هي المعركه الاطوال مئه
عام من التطور التكنولوجيه ولم يتغير
الكثير تشابه المعارك قد يقودوا الى نتائج
متطابقه فرنسا قررت مهاجمه الالمان شمالا
لتخفيف الضغط الروس يتوقعونه هجوما
اوكرانيا على الشمال ايضا في بيروت وفي
الجنوب ايضا على القمه والدليل انهم
يتحسنون هناك بينما تراجع الروس في كل
الجبهات تقدموا في بخموت ولم يتقدم الجيش
هم اكثر خبره وعتابا وربما
يريد ان يثبت انه وحقق اما عجز عنه جيش
بوتن مساله راي عام في روسيا
بعيده ابيها حرمه الجيش الاوكرانيه من
الامدادات الكهربائيه سواء في تشغيل سكك
الحديد وما يتبعها مندادات او في مراكز
الطاقه هذه الخطوه غيرت مجرى الحرب
واكسبتها طبعا جديدا مخالفا للتطورات
السابقه ودفعت الجانبين لتمركز داخل
الخنادق خلال المعارك الجاريه في دانيت
كوباخ مود وفي مناطقه اخرى
الشتاء القارصي وارتفاعه وتيره ضربات
موسكو وكيف يفرضان واقعا على العمليات
الدائره وربما لن يتوسع ان يتقوا العمليات
جراء البرد والثلوج لكن استراتيجيه قوه
فاجنر راديفا تقوم بمهمه مساعده لقوات
موسكو او بغارات النوعيه على النقاط
الحساسه لا سيما ان مقاتليفاغنر يملكون
خبرات عسكريه ميدانيه لا يستهان بها حسب
تقيمي عدد من الخبراء
بالحديث عن دروس التاريخ هناك درس اخر لكن
روسيا تعلمت افراغوا المدن الاوكرانيه من
السكان والوسيله قطعوا الكهرباء المدن
الاوكرانيه ليست دافئه الاراضي الاوكرانيه
الموحله تتجمد قريبا وعوده الهجوم الروسيه
كما ترون هنا اوكرانيا تحولت الى
ثقب اسود هكذا وصفت بروكسل المشهد القذف
الروسي افقد البلاد ثلث انتاجها من
الكهرباء
تغير المعطيات تتغير المعادله فلاحاجه
للسلاح والاموال بقدر معدات الطاقه مطالب
اوكرانيه جديده والاستجابه الغربيه حاضره
وفوريه مليار ومئه مليون دولار من واشنطن
لكن هنا تظهر معضله اخرى ضرب المحولات
عاليه الجهد اكثر من محطه انتاج الطاقه
والهدف تحويل شبكه الاوكرانيه الى شبكات
صغيره منفصله النتائج تعقدهم مهمه نقل
الكهرباء من اوروبا وهذا اتهام الامريكي
معضله ثانيه روسيا حتى الان استهدفت
محولات بقدرته 330 كيلو فولت لم تستهدف
المحولات الاكبر والسبب هو انها تنتج فقط
في روسيا لا محولات غربيه بنفس الخصائص
وبالتالي لابد من اصلاحها
كوابيسو حكومه تواجهه معدله ثالثه ضرب
محطات التدفئه وقتها المياه تتجمد داخل
الانابيب والرهان هنا شده بروده الشتاء
درجه حراره سالب 10 تمدد الجليد داخل
الانابيب وبالتالي تدمير شبكه توزيع
المياه وفي المعضلات الثانيه كان الاصلاح
صعبا اما هنا الاصلاح لن يتم الا بحلول
الربيع وبضربه محولات الطاقه الاوكرانيه
بعد ما تجرعته الصناعتها منذ بدايه الحرب
وليس بسبب الندره وانما بسبب العقوبات
الغربيه مؤثره نعم ولذلك تطالب كيف الان
بزياداتها في ما يخص انتاج الصواريخ
عديده دمرت العسكريه تحديدا واكثر
القطاعات التضررا الدبابات الروسيه سلاح
رئيسا في العقيده العسكريه نسخه تي 90
مثلا لا يمكنها القتال ليلا بكفاءه دون
نظام كافرا للتصويب الليلي للدبابات وهذا
يسمح للدبابات بتدقيق التصويب لمسافه 10
كيلو مترات ليلا وحتى وراء غطاء غابات
كثير
شركه روسيه بدعم تقنيه وقطع غيار من شركه
تليس الفرنسيه وقبل الحرب كانت روسيا تجهز
لمئتين 250 دبابه تي 9 بالنظام المتطور
لكن وبسبب العقوبات الان تعويضها باتا شبه
مستحيل كيف يؤثر ذلك على روسيا بحلول
الشتاء المعروف بلياليه الطويله في
اوكرانيا الدبابات تفقد القدره على
المناورات الليليه موسكو مضطره لتعويض
نظام كافر في معدات روسيه قديمه في تسعون
ستصبح مجرد مدرعه صوفيا التقليديه
على العقوبات تاره عبر تاسيس شركه في
هولندا لشراء ارادرات ومعالجه المتطوره
قبل ارسالها عبر بلدا ثالث وطاره عبر
الحلفاء الهند مثلا طلبت منها قائمه بال
في منتجه
يحتمل الاستخدام المزدواج المدني وعسكري
اما تركيا فتحولت اكبر من وجهه للمنتجات
المحربه وحداتها من امريكي لكن لماذا
انقره هي عضو الاتحاد الجمركي الاوروبي
امر يسهل عليها وصول السلع الغربيه بجانبي
عدم التزامها بالعقوبه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
لقد فعلها كيف استقبل بيضا الفوز الرياضي
السياسي على ايران في الساعه
بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قويه
والان تتجه نحو تدهور اكبر ولذلك وكما
شاهدنا اي تفوقا في اي مجال الرياضي منه
بالطبع ينعكسه على ساسه البلدين بعيد انا
قطع لقاء رسميا ليحتفل بفوز المنتخب
الامريكي على ايران في كاس العالم السياسه
في كره القدم رغم محاولات ابعادها دليل ان
اخر ايضا حدث بالامس تشاكا لاعب وسويسرا
واصوله من الالبانه
احتفل امس بالانتصار على الغريم الصربي
التي ترفض الاعتراف باستقلال كوسوفو عنها
بان ارتدى قميص زميله ارضنا يا شاري ماذا
يعني تشاكا بذلك ادم يا شريف كما يعرف
هناك قاده المقاومه الصوفيه ضد الصربه
و50 شخصا من عائلته على القوات الصبيه
لماذا لا يطلق الجيش النار على فلسطينيا
اي يحملوا حجرا وزجاجه حارقه حتى دون ان
يلقيها هذا تساؤل لاثمار ابن كثير الزعيم
حزب القوه اليهوديه اليمنيه المتطرف في
اسرائيل تسال يتجه ليصبح واقعا بالكفير
تولى حقيبه الامن الداخلي بموجب اتفاق
الائتلافي بين حزب القوه اليهوديه وحزب
الكود ابي رئاسه ابن يمين نتنياهو وصوله
بالف خير ان يقلقوا الداخل والخارج في
اسرائيل لماذا تاريخ الرجل عنصريه متطرف
وموقفه الان حساس جدا بصلاحيات واسعه غير
مسبوقه قد تتخطى صلاحيات القاده العسكريين
حتى طموح بنت فير ان لن يقف عند احد
شرعانته وتوسعه المستوطنات في الضفه
الغربيه بل سيستثمر في برنامجه الطموح
تشكيل مجموعات مسلحه من ابناء المستعمرات
يمتلك الرجل صلاحيات وميزانيه ماليه تمنحه
ذراعا امنيا ليس داخل اسرائيل فحسب وانما
في الضفه الغربيه ايضا لكن الاخطر تمويل
مشروعه لتحويل قوه مستوطنين الى قوه
المنظمه والعدد يقدر ب 200 الفلاح خطرا
تحسسه برينجلز وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
هاجم صلاحيات الممنوحه لبنك فير لكنه يخشى
السيناريو الاسواق يخشى تشكيله ميليشيا
ايضا انهيار الاوضاع في الضفه الغربيه
وبنكير على الراس قوات حرس الحدود في
الامس القريب كان يطالب بقتل من يحمل حجرا
او زجاجه حارقه لكن اليوم خرج في تسريبنا
ايحذر انصاره منه محاوله التسرع في تنفيذ
اجددته فهل يريد تنفيذها ببطء يبدو ذلك
احتمالا اقرب فالرجل قدمت ضده ثلاث وخمسون
لائحه اتهام بممارسه العنف او التحريض
عليه بل اودين سابقا بتهمه العنصريه ودعم
الارهاب
هل حصل بن كفيرا على ما يريد نعم الاتفاق
واعتبرته وقياده اسرائيليه وصمت عار وان
بنكفير هو رئيس الوزراء وليس نتنياهو لكن
لماذا
تقلقوا والصلاحيات الواسعه قياده
اسرائيليه وما يطال منها الجيش الاسرائيلي
واعتبر ذلك تاسيسا لعمل الجيش فتغيير
مرجعيه حارس الحدود من الجيش الى بنت فير
يعني اول تاثيرا على الجيش والتداخل في
الصلاحيات بين المؤسسه العسكريه وحرس
الحدود والعالم ما يخشاه القاده العسكريون
اطال براسه جندي اسرائيلي يهدد النشطاء
تضاما مع اهل الخليل المثير في مقاله
اهدر
مشاهد الغربيه
يدرك هو ان المضيء بسرعه كبيره في تنفيذ
اجنته له عواقب لذا فالرجل يمضي بحذر
ويحذر انصاره اذا هو تكيف مع المرحله
المقبله سواء من بنفيرو وانصاره او حتى من
بقيه اجهزه الدوله ومؤسساتها وبدا هذا
واضحا فيما اتخذته مفاوضات السجون
الاسرائيليه من اجراء لاقاله قائد السجن
جلبوع في اعقب اخفاقات اكو شفا عنها في
سجون الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وعمليه نفق
الحريه التي نفذها سته اسرى فلسطينيين
وفروا من السجن في سبتمبر من العام الماضي
اجراءات تستبق وصوله بنت اجراءات اللي
تتكيف مع خطط وزير الامن القومي المقبل من
الواضح ان البنك يتجه نحو مزيدا من التشدد
في السجون وفرد المزيد من القيود على
الاسرى
تسميه النائب المتطرف ايثمار بن كبير
وزيرا للامن القومي في اسرائيل بمثابه من
يضع القتل حراسه اللبن براي مراقبين في
اسرائيل فهو سيكون مسؤولا عن حرس الحدود
في الضفه الغربيه المحتله لقد يشعل الوضع
اكثر هناك والاخطار بانه مسؤول عن الشرطه
الاسرائيليه واقتحامات المسجد الاقصى لان
مخططه وتقسيم المكان والسماح للمتطرفين
اليهود بصلاته هناك ما قد يشعل حربا على
قطاع غزه وان لم يكن ذلك كافيا فقد يؤدي
الى توتر الاوضاع داخل اسرائيل بين اليهود
والعرب واكثر من ذلك سيوتر العلاقه اكثر
بين نتنياهو والاداره الامريكيه
لمتابعه هذا الملف ينضم الينا عبر سكايب
رمضان ابو جزر المحلل السياسي ومدير مركز
بروكس الدولي للبحوث اهلا بك اذا حكومه
يتخوف منها الكثيرون في اسرائيل كما في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه وحتى في مراكز صنع
القرار الدولي يعني
حضر في
تسجيلها مسرب ايضا من مخاوفه من بنك
رئيس الحكومه السابق تحدث عن الفاشيه على
احدى الاذاعات والساعه نتنياهو للتحالف مع
الصهيونيه الدينيه المكونه من ايضا ثلاثه
مكونات لها ميليشيات هذا يندر بانفجار
الاوضاع الصحيح
ااا نحن امام ااا اكبر حكومه متطرفه في
هذا العصر الحديث وهذه الحكومه لم تاتي
بالصدفه ولم تاتي نتيجه رغبه نتنياهو هي
نتيجه مزاج اسرائيلي متطرف جدا هذا الشعب
الاسرائيلي هو الذي انتخب واختار هذه
الحكومه المتطرفه وهذه تنذر نذير شؤم على
المنطقه وبالعكس همم هذه الحكومه هي التي
تعري وجه اسرائيل الحقيقي الذي يمكن للبعض
ان كانوا قد خدعوا همم
باسرائيل وباعلامها وما تصدره من
ديمقراطيه هذه الديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه
تصدر لنا مجرمه حرب مدانين في محاكم
اسرائيليه
او نريد ان نلفت ايضا الى نلفت الى تصريح
بني جانس تحدث عن قوات حرس الحدود هو يظهر
امامنا الان سيطرت على شرطه الحدود بالضفه
الغربيه ستتسبب بضرر جسيم للامن لماذا فقط
الحدود هل تختلف الحكومات هل في القوى
الاسرائيليه
هناك خلافات عديده بين التيارات السياسيه
الاسرائيليه والطرق ادارتها لاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله وهذا شان اسرائيلي
ولكن المعالم الواضحه ان هذا اليمين متطرف
جاء بخطاب حرب خطاب حرب بدات بواديره
ظاهره للعالم بالامس عندما قام جندي
اسرائيلي بقتل اعدام ميداني لشاب فلسطيني
مدني لا يحمل ادنى سلاحا وهذه هي بوادر
همم معالم حكومه يكون على راس الامن او
وزير الامن فيها هو بنجير اذا يبدو ان
الجنود الاسرائيليين المتطرفين التابعين
لهذه الاحزاب
يرون في هذه الحكومه تصريحا واطلاق يد لهم
لممارسه جرائم ضد الفلسطينيين في الضفه
الغربيه وقطاع غزه همم الخلاف الاس
الاسرائيلي بين الاحزاب الاسرائيليه
والشخصيات الاسرائيليه التي فشلت في
الانتخابات الماضيه لا يعطي شهاده براءه
او شرف للسياسه الاسرائيليه السياسه
الاسرائيليه هي مبنيه
من ماذا يتخوفون هل يتخوفون من لوائح
الاتهام الجنائيه 53 ااا يعني لائحه اتهام
بحق بنفير هل يتخوفون ايضا من قضايا
الفساد واخرى لمسؤولين اخرين وزراء ربما
سيكونون في هذه الحكومه هم من يعني
معروفون بعمليات غسله لاموال هل هذا ما
يتخوفون منه
اذا كان رصيد بنغفير وغيره من المتطرفين
كل هذا الكم من الجرائم والمحاكمات
والايدانات على مدى اكثر من 20 سنه ويسمح
لهم للوصول الى المناصب الوزاريه السيا
ديه فاين هذه الاستقلاليه اين هذا الخطاب
اين هذا التوجه لدى اوروبا والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه كل الحق في التخوف من
هذا اليمين المتطرف الذي يمكن ان يعصف في
المنطقه في حال ونحن نمر بحمليه ركود
لعمليه السلام ولكن هناك عمل على الارض
يمكن ان يزيد وتيته من استيطان ومن قتل
جماعي ولا ناسه مشروع نتنياهو ضم الاغوار
سوف يعود الان مجددا هذا الضم عندما يتحكم
من اليمين وتطرف في وزاره الماليه فتسمح
به رصد موازنه ضخمه لاعاده الاستيطان من
جديد يشكل خطرا على الاردن وخطرا على
عمليه السلام برمتها عندما يقوم بالكفير
على همم على جهاز الامن الاسرائيلي او
وزاره الداخليه الاسرائيليه سوف يشكل
مواجهه مباشره حتى معجزه الامن الفلسطيني
ولكن هناك هناك تسريب مثير اليوم فلتبقى
معنا همم سنتابع معك هذا الجزء من تسريبات
بالكبير التي طالب فيها انصاره بعدم تنفيذ
اجنداته بشكل سريع سنعود اليك
شكرا شكرا
[موسيقى]
يعني ربما ياتي هذا التسجيل او تسريب
الصوتيه بعد
اقاله مفاوضات السجون الاسرائيليه قائد
السجن جلبوع لكن يبدو ان هناك من يتحمس
اكثر حتى من من من من كفير على تنفيذ هذه
الاجنده
لا يمكن لا يجب ان ننجر وراء خطاب من هنا
وتسريب هناك فير هذا برنامج هو العالم
الذي وصل به الى عضويه الكنيسه هو برنامج
مبني في الاساس على مدى 20 عام على قتل
العرب وترحيل العرب واسرائيل اليوم تربطها
بعمليات سلام مع عده الدول العربيه كيف
سوف تتعامل الدول العربيه التي وقعت
اتفاقيه سلام مع اسرائيل ما حكومه مشكله
من احزاب تنادي بقتل العرب بالمناسبه
الفلسطينيه ليسوا وحدهم عرب هناك 22 دوله
عربيه وهذا بينكفير
ده باليمين المتطرف كلها تنظر بفوقيه
وباستعلاء وبحقد شديد على العرب وتنادي في
خطاباتهم الداخليه حتى لقتل العرب وليس
لقتل الفلسطينيين لذ
لك تخوف حقيقي غربي وامريكي وفي لدى
اليسار الاسرائيلي من وجود هذه الحكومه
بهذا الشكل في بدايه عملها يمكن ان تفضح
وجه اسرائيل الحقيقي ويمكن ان تخسر
اسرائيل دول عربيه قد ايه ارتئت بتعزيز
معسكر السلام مع اسرائيل من خلال توقيع
اتفاقيات سلام ولكن يبدو ان العكس هو الذي
حدث وهذا العكس الذي حدث يحرج دول بعينها
وخاصه دول حدوديه مثل الاردن ومصر ويمكن
ان يشكل ضغطا كبيرا على هذه الدول ويمكن
ان نشهد تراجع عن او تجميد لعم سلام وقعت
مع اسرائيل نتيجه لوجود هذه الحكومه هذه
الحكومه هي حكومه حرب حكومه تطرف همم حتى
في اروقه البرلمان الاوروبي شاهدنا بالامس
وباول امس دعوات لعدم استقبال اي وزير
اسرائيلي وانا اؤكد انه لن يجد اي وزير من
هذه الحكومه وخاصه بنت فير اي اا
تجاوبالا
تحدثت عنه مصادر ايضا في الاعلام
الاسرائيلي عن همم يعني ممكن اقدام واشنطن
على مقاطعه همم لكن ايضا هناك تحرك
دبلوماسي غير مسبوق همم اتخذته اداره بيضا
وهو قرار تعيين هذه عمره لمنصب ممثل خاصه
للشؤون الفلسطينيه هذه الخطوه غير
المسبوقه مع هذه الايه التصريحات ربما
لمصادر
كيف سيكون شكل العلاقات مع حكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو
اصلا حكومه علاقه الديمقراطيه نتنياهو لم
تكن جيده ايبان حكم اوباما ومن ثم
العلاقات لم تكن جيده عندما كانت تحالف
واضحا بيننا ثاني ياهو ترامب الخصم
الحقيقي للرئيس الحالي بيدن ولكن لا يمكن
البناء في العلاقات او البراهنه على
الخلافات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه لانه هناك
لوبي اسرائيل قوي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه سوف يبقى يظل يدعم لدوله
الاحتلال اما الخلافات مع اليمين واليمين
المتطرف همم بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا يجب علينا كرب بناء همم كثير
من الامال على هذه الخلافات لان اتخذ هذا
القرار فقط للتلويح نتنياهو بعدم اطلاق يد
او بعدم اعطاء صلاحيات كبيره لبنغافير
فقام نتنياهو بالاتفاق ما بيننا كثير
واعطائه وصلاحيات على الجيش وزاره الامن
الداخلي لاي اكثر مما توقعه الامريكان لا
تحت نتنياهو خطير جدا ورحمه الله على
صوابعه التي كان يصفون دائما بالكاذب
والمجرم وهو المخطط ومن خلال هذه
التوافقات لتشكيل حكومه نتنياهو ليس مضطرا
ولكن هذه رغبه تتنياهو لاشعال المنطقه
والخروج بمظهر انه هو رجل السلام الوحيد
ولا في اسرائيل والذي يجب على العالم
التعامل معه وانه محاط بالمتطرفين جدا هذه
سياسه يتقنها ثاني ياهو ليخدع بها الشارع
لصلاح الدين العربي ولا يخدع المجتمع
الدولي شكرا لكم معنا رمضان ابو الجزائر
المحلل السياسي ومدير مركز بروكسل الدوليه
للبحوث
[موسيقى]
كمبيوتر
النجل الرئيس الامريكي كلمه السر واحده
لفتحه واسرار كثيره بداخله
على كثره الجبهات المعارك التي يفتحها على
نفسها وسنتطرق لها بعد قليل فتحها اخرى
جديده بايضا القطار بدات عام 2020 تويتر
قيد الوصول الى مقالات حول كمبيوتر
وابهرت استغلال النفود السياسيه في
التعاملات التجاريه ماسك التحود على تويتر
من البريد الالكتروني للمنصه حول القرار
ساظهر الوثائق هكذا تحدث ماسك كلماته
مدعومه باستطلاعات للراي ستطون في المئه
من الامريكيين يعتبرون ان الكمبيوتر الخاص
مهمه وانا ايضا قد يكون متورطا في تعاملات
ليس ماسكه واحده
الجمهوريون ايضا بداوا طبعا فتحه ملفاتهم
وايضا بدعم استطاعات الراي
62% من الامريكيين يدعمون التحقيق مع
هنتربايدل وكلمه مؤثر الجمهوريه هناك ما
ذكرنا فيها كمبيوتر
هانتربوينتر لاشهر في ورشه لصيانه
الحواسيب لناخذكم في هذه الرحله شركه
الغاز الاوكرانيه بوريسيما احدى كلمات
السر داخل هذا الكمبيوتر عامله هنتر عضوا
بمجلس ادارتها عام 2014 وهذه امور عاديه
ما غير العاديه هو راتبه ثلاثه وثمنون الف
دولار شهريا هل يستحقوا وهنتربوينت المبلغ
لا اجابه قاطعه لكن المعطيات هي انها
خبراته ضعيفه وتحديدا في قطاع الغاز
راتبه هانتر لطالما اثار التساؤلات وعندما
تخرج حصل على وظيفه براتب عالم في شركه
امبي ان اي بمسخه راس والده شركه ادعمها
بيضا في مجلس الشيوخ
لنعود الان الى بورسما وقتها كان بايضا
نائبا للرئيس فهل الامر صله
بعد تركي بيضه لمنصبه من 83 الفن الى
41.000$ وهنا يظهر فيكتور
عام اوكرانيا
فساد للشركه التي اسسها اصلا وزير البيئه
الاوكرانيه السابق بسكي وكانت تمنح تراخيص
الاستكشاف التي استفادت منها بوريسما وهنا
يظهر ايضا نائب الرئيس حينها بايضا كان
مكلفا بمحاربه الفساد في اوكرانيا
ديسمبر 2015 سافر الى كياب ودق خطا على
الحكومه الاوكرانيه لا نريد هذا المدعي
العام وبالفعل اجبر شوكين على ترك منصبه
في 2016 بعدين لم ينكر دوره في ذلك لكن بح
جه
انفوني 60
[موسيقى]
عبر فتحي ملفات بتحقيقات عديده تخص
التعاملات الماليه والتجاريه
الخارجيه
ربما عرضت البيت الابيض للخطر وبالتالي
فهي مصدر قلق للامن القومي
مهنه والده السياسيه الناجحه لاسراء نفسه
وانهم ضمه الى مجلس اداره شركه غاز طبيعي
اوكرانيا عام 2019 كما ساعدت شركه
استثماريه شارك هنتر في تاسيسها شركه
صينيه على شراء منجم كوبال في الكونغو من
شركه امريكيه عام 2016
وبينما يخدع حاليا لتحقيق في دليل في
وزاره العدل في شان انتهاكات ضريبيه
محتمله تتعلق بعمله في الخارج كذلك مساءا
بانه بيان كاذب اثناء شراء سلاح الا انه
لم توجه له اتهامات باي جرائم حتى الان
لكنها تربايدن يصر على ان تعاملاته
الماليه والتجاريه في الصين واوكرانيا
كانت قانونيه على رغم اعترافه بان حياته
المهنيه استفادت على الارجح من الروابط
العائليه
بعيدا عن اوكرانيا يقع جزء كبير من شبكه
التجاريه العابره في شرق القاره الصين
تحديدا
بي اتش ار الصينيه مع حلو تركيز في 2013
في مجلس اداره الشركه لاداره صناديق
الاستثمار في الاسهم هذه الشركه ساهمت في
ديسمبر 2001 حسب نيويورك تايمز في عمليه
استحواذ شركه
الصينيه على واحد من اغنى مناجم القبل وهو
المعدن الرئيسي في تصنيعه بطاريات
السيارات الكهربائيه في الكونغو
الديمقراطيه وفي العالم الاستحواذ تم من
شركه امريكيه
ضرب مصالح طبعا نحن في العام 2019 شركه
ثقه النوويه صينيه اسمها سي جي ام باور
جروب في القائمه السوداء للتصدير الامريكي
وشركه بي اتش ار كانت المستثمر الرئيسي
عندك كتاب الشركه الصينيه في بورصه
استفاده هنكر اربعه ملايين 8400 الف دولار
دفعتها الشركه لكيانه يسيطر عليها هنتر
وعمو
واشنطن بوست تتحدث
2014 واشنطن وضعت شركه ابيك اوتو الصينيه
على القائمه السوداء للتصدير لكن رغم ذلك
تعاونن في 2015 بين بي اتش ار والشركه
الام الشركه الصينيه اباك للاستحواذي على
شركه هناجس اوتو موتيف الامريكيه لتصنيعه
مكونات السيارات وبموافقه من لجنه
الاستثمار الاجنبي في امريكا لكن اللجنه
كانت تحت اداره
وزير الخارجيه وقتها جون كيري وزوج والده
شريكان في الشركه الصينيه
للصلابه وبالتالي فهو هدف سهل لتحقيقات
الجمهوريين لكن هل هذه التحقيقات قد طالوا
بايدا في الوقت الحالي
الحجه هنا انه كان على علم لكن على مدار
سنوات نفر رئيس الامريكي علمه بانشطه نجله
التجاريه ورغم ذلك فوكس نيوز اوردت دليلا
على علم بايدا التقى 14 من شركاء ابنه
تجاريين في الداخل وفي المكسيك في
اوكرانيا الصين وهكذا غسان اثناء توليه
منصب نائب الرئيس نحن في 2019 المكان
هكذاخستان نشر موقعنا مهتم بناء بمحاربه
الفساد صوره تجمع بيضا بكل من رئيس
الوزراء السابق كريم مازموف ورجل الاعمال
كنس الركيب
علاقته الاخير التجاريه بعنطر كانت محلات
تساؤلات
بين والده وبين راكشيف الذي كان يتطلع الى
استثمار جزء من ثروته في نيويورك و واشنطن
ونفادا وهذه المره العهده على بديل لكن
بعيدا واهنتر اتخذ قرار بعدم التحدث عن
هذه الامور ما اعرض كلاهما للهجوم حتى
داخل اداره الرئيس الاسبق اوباما كانت
غاضبه بحسب تحقيقا لنيويورك
اوباما ازدادت في ديسمبر 2015 مع اقتراب
المعركه الرئاسيه مع الجمهوريين لجلسه
مصحف ستايل المبعوث الخاص لاداره اوباما
لسياسه الطاقه
الخاصه بشركه الغاز الاوكرانيه بوريسيما
كانت صلبه
اتمنى ان تكون على درايه بكل ما تفعله
عبارات بيضا لنجله هنتر ابي حسب نيويوركير
فهل كان هنتر على درايه ام انه تورط وورط
والدهما
وتماكن
ايام البيت الابيض السعيده
[موسيقى]
قبل اسبوعين كنا قد حذرنا في الساعه ستونه
من ضروره الاستعداد لمرحله ما بعد تويتر
كثيرون سنباوا بسيناريو الانهيار اليوم
ماسك اعترف بالورقه الافلاس ليس مستبعدا
وغرد بان السعر الذي دفعه لقاء عمليه
الاستحواذ كان غير عادل كلام ماسك يبدو
دقيقا للغايه ارادات الشركه اقل بكثير من
مصروفاتها ومنذ اليوم الاول ماسك حمل
ميزانيه الشركه 13 مليار دولار ديونا
اضافيه الى جانبي مديونيه الخمسه مليار
دولار السابقه لعمليه الاستحباب هناك
كارثه وبالفوائد الشركه مول زمان بدفع
مليار ومئتين مليون دولار كفائده على
خدمته الدين البالغه ثلاثه عشر مليارات
وهذه الفائده متغيره ومرشحه للارتفاع
تماشيا مع سياسه البنك الفدراليه الحاليه
لمعالجه ازمه التضخم في امريكا قبل
افتح بعد كانت 100 مليون دولار فقط مع هذا
عانت الشركه لتحقيق الارباح والان الوضع
بات اسوا بكثير ويستلزم عمليه عاجله حتى
البنوك التي مولد عمليه الاستحواذ تبحث عن
من يشتري السندات في صناديق التحول او
عرضت كل دولارا مقابل 70 سنه فقط وهي
محاوله للتخلص من اي ارتباط مع الشركه على
المدى البعيد الواقع ان الوسيله الوحيده
لتظل الشركه موجوده على المدى القريب هي
ان يقوم ماسك بحل ما في شعوبته بمعنى ان
يبيع اسومه في ليحصل على الكاش السيوله
ويسدد الديون الشركه كي لا تعلن افلاسها
ماسكه على ذلك ما قيمته 20 مليار دولار من
اسومه في تسلا وبشكلنا متفرق خلال العامين
الماضيه لكن الى متى قد يخطر ببال البعض
ان الامر لن يكون غصبا على ماسك لكن
الحقيقه ان ماسك قد يضطر الى تاجيل رحلته
الى المريخ قليلا امام هذه المعضلات ليست
من عاده رجال الفضاء التخلي عن طموحاتهم
بسهوله اذا ماذا يدور في عقله غير
الارتجال والتسرع وكره تويتر الازرق التي
لا تحقق اراده قويه بل وتنفر المعلمين
هناك فكره اخرى اقترحها ماسك في كواليس
الاستماع الاول قال والروايه على عهدتي
موقع دا برج الامريكي لماذا لا ندعوا اكبر
صنع المحتوى على يوتيوب لمنصتنا ونفع لهم
10% اكثر فماذا يحدث اذا نجحت الفكره قد
يتحول تويتر الى اكبر منافس لليوتيوب
واحده من انجح من الصفات الحاليه لعرض
الفيديوهات
جديته ماسك بهذه بهذا الشان ظاهره قبل
اسبوع محادثه عالميه على تويتر بينهم وبين
واحدا من اهم صان المحتوى على يوتيوب مستر
بست المحماسك لا هو ان تويتر يدرس رفعته
اراده الفيديو من المشاهده ماذا يعني ذلك
بلغه عالم الصانع المحتوى يعني الملايين
لكن كيف صناعه المحتوى الكبار في يوتيوب
يكسبون تقريبا 17 جنيها استرلينيا لكل
المشاهده لانه هو فيديو واحد من فيديوهات
مستر بن يكسب الرجل خمسه ملايين جنيه
مقطع لديه 300 مليون مشاهده مثلا نعم هذا
صحيح خمسه ملايين للفيديو الواحد واذا كسر
ماسك هذه الحسبه التي تعد من بين الاعلى
في السوق ورفعها فلا شك ان عالم وسائل
التواصل سيشهده هجره افتراضيه تاريخيه
افكار وماسك لا تنتهي لديه فكره اخرى لكن
هذه المره في جبهه الصراع اخرى مع ابل
باعلان مالك تويتر الجديد قالوا الماسك
استعداده لخوض حرب مع شركه ابل بدل دفع
رسوم لها لتحميل التطبيقي من متجر اب ستور
التي تصل الى 30% ينضم تويتر الى حرب
موجوده
قدمت شكاوى ضد الاحتكار ضد ابل في اوروبا
في ما رفعت جيمز دعوه قضائيه ضدها في
الولايات المتحده عام 2020 وفي مؤشر على
هذا الحلف الثلاثي المحتمل اعاد المديران
التنفيذيان الشركتين جيمز وصفات
تغريدات مصر المتعلقه باب ستار والرسوم
نعم سيتاثر راسنا المحتوى ايجابيا لكن
واثقا للقاعده العامه هناك ربح النعم لكن
هناك ايضا خاسر وفي معادله تويتر نادي
الخاسرين كان اكثر من الرابحين والصحفيون
قد يخسرون اذا انهار تويتر نحن هو من منصه
الساعه 60 يمكننا الجزماء بان عمل الصحفي
بات مرتبطا في جزء كبير بوجود هذه المساحه
ربما ساعدت سياسه التغريدات المختصره
سابقا باستقطاب في هذا العالم التقنيه
البسيطه ايضا كان لها دور كبير عندك صحفي
تتابع جهات من خبراء او سياسيين يوفرون لك
المعلومات
بنسختها الرقم
المسؤول عن تحرير في معهد المعهد الوطني
الفرنسي للمواد السماعيه والمصريه بل تطور
الامر لان تصبح المنصوره
ومصدرا للسبق الصحفي قبل ان يتدهور الوضع
كثيرا وتصبح المنصه حلبه مصارعه بين
الانتماءات المختلفه تويتر يدمر الصحافه
الامريكيه هكذا يرى مثلا الكاتب في صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز مانجو وذلك مع الوصول عدد
المستخدمين ل 2007 وثلاثون مليون مزاد من
هامش نشر الاخبار المضلله امر اخر يؤثر
ايضا على الصحافه ما يجعل النعمه تتحول
لنغمه لكن الكابوس الاسود ان يفشل المالك
الجديد الذي لا يخفى كرهه للصحفينا في
انقاذ الشركه لربما حان الوقت كما يقول
احد الصحفيين ان يعود الصحفيون الى طرق
اعملهم التقليديه في البحث المعلومات
حفله عشاء ماء فاخر على شرطي شرفي ضيفي
واشنطن وحليفها الاقدم رئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون يبدو انه عاد اخيرا ايام
السعاده للبيت الابيض وفي الحقيقه السعاده
لحظه وبهذه اللحظه نختم الساعه ومن الان
وحتى الساعه المقبله انا حنين السوري وهبي
[موسيقى]